ein blick in die tageszeitungen genügt
um zu erkennen dass immer mehr
europäische staaten wie auch die
europäische union unter druck geraten
der brh exit und forderungen von
us-präsident trump überdecken dabei
viele tiefergehende entwicklungen
denn der geopolitische machtkampf
zwischen den usa china und russland hat
erhebliche auswirkungen auf die lage und
sicherheit europas heute in vechta
kompakt europa gerät unter druck
[Musik]
nur einige beispiele zur illustration
der aktuellen entwicklung die kündigung
des vertrags die russische agitation in
europa dass iran abkommen und chinas
vormarsch
zum ersten die usa und russland kündigen
den vertrag über atomare
mittelstreckenraketen auf der kreml
verstärkt seine truppen auf der krim und
positionierte raketen in kaliningrad
die kämpfe in der ost ukraine gehen
unvermindert weiter
politik und experten befürchten bereits
ein wettrüsten und die neuerliche
stationierung von atomwaffen mitten in
europa dieses befindet sich nach wie vor
unter dem nuklearen schutzschirm der usa
und profitiert und amerikanischen
abschreckung doch wie lange noch und um
welchen preis wir können die ganz geht
man in die wertung
erst an zweitens das eu-parlament und
der auslandsgeheimdienst estlands warnen
eindringlich vor russische agitation mit
der eu staaten und regierungen
destabilisiert werden sollen die wahlen
zum eu parlament ende mai 2009 10 bieten
einen perfekten anlass dafür eine
entspannung in den russisch europäischen
beziehungen zeichnet sich nicht ab
ebenso wenig eine aufhebung der infolge
der annexion der krim verhängten
sanktionen
die einzige strategische konstante
zwischen russland und vielen eu staaten
bilden öl und gaslieferungen die
allerdings auch für politische zwecke
missbraucht werden können
dabei drängt washington europäische
abnehmer vor allem deutschland die
abhängigkeit von russischen
energieträgern zu reduzieren und bietet
im gegenzug us lieferungen an die eu
befindet sich in der zwickmühle und
ringt um eine einheitliche position zum
dritten washington hat sich einseitig
vom nokia abkommen mit dem raum
zurückgezogen und möchte ein rigoroses
sanktionen gegenüber teheran
installieren
ebenso plant es die sanktionen gegenüber
russland drastisch zu verschärfen in
beiden fällen sind eu-staaten und
europäische firmen negativ betroffen
sie werden aber nicht in die
entscheidungen eingebunden die eu ist
bestrebt dieses nuklear abkommen am
leben zu erhalten und damit auch
einfluss hinsichtlich einer positiven
und moderaten entwicklung im iran und im
nahen osten nehmen zu können
weitere sanktionen sind aus europäischer
perspektive kontraproduktiv zu dem
schaden sie der europäischen wirtschaft
brüssel versucht hier bereits einen
europäischen sonderweg zu gehen
und viertens china ist mit der neuen
seidenstraße auch in europa auf dem
vormarsch
das chinesische engagement wir zunehmend
mit argwohn gesehen wenn es um kritische
infrastruktur oder den rw
modernster technologien geht denn die
angst nimmt zu dass peking druck auf
seine firmen ausüben und zu handlangern
einer expansiven außenpolitik machen
könnte die gesetzlichen grundlagen dafür
sind vorhanden
aktuell drängt der chinesische anbieter
war beim aufbau der zukunfts
bestimmenden 5 g/t auf dem markt
australien neuseeland und die usa aber
auch polen haben wir wegen
sicherheitsbedenken als anbieter bereits
ausgeschlossen
washington warnt europäische staaten
auch österreich eindringlich davor
pekings einfluss steigt aber auch in
konkurrenz zur eu in osteuropa und auf
dem westbalkan der eu-kommissar für
erweiterung der österreicher johannes
hand warnt daher bereits vor neuen
abhängigkeiten unter dem abbau
politischer standards dadurch könnten
die umfangreichen und kostspieligen
bemühungen der eu hinsichtlich
transformation der politischen systeme
und gesellschaftlicher versöhnung
konterkariert werden
was heißt das nun für die eu die usa
russland und china sind einer starken eu
und japan interessiert wenn es ihren
politischen und wirtschaftlichen
interessen dient ihr strategisches
kalkül geht somit eher in richtung
schwächung des zusammenhalts
fragmentierung oder destabilisierung
kino steigenden einfluss sie russische
propaganda die lockrufe der usa
gegenüber einzelnen eu staaten diese
erkenntnis verlangt eine nüchterne
bestandsaufnahme der geopolitischen
entwicklungen der position und rolle der
eu im globalen wettbewerb sowie im
sicherheitsbereich vorzunehmen und
ableitungen aus eu perspektive zu
treffen
ein ausblick die globale strategie der
eu aus dem jahr 2016 betonten mehrfach
die notwendigkeit einer strategischen
autonomie also der unabhängigkeit und
handlungsfähigkeit
die rasanten globalen veränderungen
unterstreichen dieses erfordernis europa
darf dabei den anschluss nicht verlieren
die europäischen staaten haben die
möglichkeit im rahmen der eu geschlossen
zu handeln
nur so haben sie die chance im
geostrategischen wettbewerb als akteur
und gestalter
auf zu trinken